Вітаю, друзі, мене
звати Марія Растворова.
Я вчитель географії Новопечерської школи.
Сьогодні ми продовжуємо вивчення
курсу географії для 10 класу.
І темою нашого уроку сьогодні
є населення Америки.
Історія заселення континенту.
Система розселення
та урбанізаційні процеси.
Для початку пропоную згадати
матеріали попереднього уроку
та ваші загальні знання.
Питання перше.
Які природні умови характерні для
материків Північна та Південна Америка?
Друге питання: хто і коли з мандрівників
вперше досяг берегів Америки?
І третє питання: які цікаві факти ви
знаєте про Американський континент?
Відповіли? Молодці, рухаємося далі.
Також надам правильні відповіді
на питання для самоперевірки,
які були в минулій презентації.
Правильна відповідь на питання
номер 1 – варіант Б.
Правильна відповідь на друге
питання – варіант В.
Правильна відповідь на питання
під номером 3 – варіант Г.
Сподіваюся, що у всіх співпало.
Рухаємося далі.
Пропоную дати відповідь на питання.
Звідки та коли в Америці
з'явилися перші люди?
А відповідь є наступною,
що 30-25 тисяч років тому
пращури корінних народів
Америки дісталися
до місця через Берингову протоку,
яка сполучає Азію та Аляску.
На Американському континенті,
так само як і в багатьох
інших первісних людей,
основою господарства переселенців
було полювання та збиральництво,
а згодом зародилося землеробство.
Тож тепер пропоную дізнатися,
які корінні народи населяли
Американський континент
в давні часи та чим вони
переважно займалися.
З розвитком осілого життя
на початку нової ери
прадавні американці вже
вміли вирощувати картоплю,
боби, тютюн, кукурудзу, або маїс,
томати та інші рослинні культури.
Також вони одомашнювали
таких диких тварин,
як альпаки, свині, індики та навчилися
виготовляти тканини
й випалювати кераміку.
Також у давніх корінних народів
Америки були свої власні знання
з астрономії, які характеризувалися
високим рівнем розвитку.
Важливо зазначити,
що в 10-15 столітті нашої ери
вже на території
Американського континенту
утворилися нові політичні
та культурні центри.
Зокрема, важливо згадати
царство ацтеків із центром
у місті Теночтітлан,
тепер це місто Мехіко,
одне із найбільш давніх міст світу.
Також на Американському континенті
існувала держава інків
з такими великими центрами,
як Куско та Мачу-Пікчу.
До речі, Мачу-Пікчу зображено на слайді.
І також на Американському континенті
була така держава майя
зі столицею Чичен-Іца.
Втім, життя корінного населення
Америки докорінно змінилося
починаючи з кінця 15 століття,
коли Американський континент
став відомий для європейців.
Нагадаю, що людиною, яка дісталася
Американського континенту
в 1492 році, був Христофор Колумб.
Після відкриття Америки Колумбом
почалися драматичні та трагічні події
для корінного населення Америки.
Починаючи з кінця 15 століття відбувалася
колонізація цього континенту,
що супроводжувалася пограбуванням
і винищуванням корінного населення.
Колонізатори, або, як їх
називають іще, конкістадори,
насаджували свої релігії в Центральній
та Південній Америці,
здебільшого це був католицизм.
Цей колоніальний період тривав
до кінця 18 століття
в Північній Америці
і закінчився з утворенням
та здобуттям незалежності
такої великої та в майбутньому
потужної держави,
як Сполучені Штати Америки.
А вже протягом наступного, 19 століття,
національні держави
виникли в Латинській Америці.
Також у ті часи процвітало таке
явище, як работоргівля.
Для освоєння Нового світу
потрібна була робоча сила
і тому вихідців з Африки
завозили як рабів.
Можливо, ви читали таку книжку
Гаррієт Бічер-Стоу «Хатина дядька Тома»,
там якраз і розповідається про непросте
життя рабів у тогочасній Америці.
Наразі загальна чисельність населення
всього Американського континенту,
тобто включаючи Північну Америку,
Центрального Америку,
країни Карибського басейну
та Південну Америку,
складає близько 1 мільярда осіб.
Переважно країни і Північної,
і Південної Америки
є іммігрантськими країнами.
Так, у Північній Америці
іммігранти та їх нащадки
складають 95 відсотків населення,
а в Південній Америці – 80 відсотків.
Таким чином, формування населення
Америки відбувалося
через міжрасові та міжетнічні взаємодії,
у зв'язку з чим нації Америки
мають поліетнічну структуру.
Зокрема, на слайді ви бачите фото одного
з американських президентів.
Це Барак Обама. І він якраз є
представником такої поліетнічної нації.
Також якщо говорити про мови,
то основними мовами
Американського континенту є
англійська, французька та іспанська.
Також дуже багато сучасних
національних держав
Американського континенту зберігають
європейські традиції.
Як вже згадувала раніше,
понад 80 відсотків населення
Американського континенту
сповідують християнство,
переважно католицизм та інші його види.
Це пов’язано з колоніальним впливом.
Зокрема, на слайді ви бачите на гравюрі
зображення двох місіонерів,
які проповідували в Каліфорнії.
Щодо урбанізаційних процесів
на Американському континенті,
то протягом усього періоду тут
переважали урбанізаційні форми
розселення, тобто міст було набагато
більше, ніж сільської місцевості.
І наразі урбанізація складає
приблизно 80 відсотків.
Тепер пропоную дізнатися більше
про чисельність населення
та його особливості в різних субрегіонах
Американського континенту.
Розпочнемо ми з Північної Америки.
Чисельність населення Північної Америки
складає 359 мільйонів осіб,
це 4,7 відсотка населення від усього
світу, за даними 2017 року.
Населення Північної Америки
характеризується
строкатим етнічним складом.
Це означає, що у США і Канаді
є представники корінних народів,
але переважно це нащадки
європейців, афроамериканців.
Іі якщо говорити про етнічну
структуру населення,
то близько 80 відсотків – це європейці,
10 відсотків – афроамериканці
і також значна частина
вихідців із країн Азії.
Не можна оминути увагою корінне
населення Північної Америки.
Це переважно нащадки
різноманітних індіанських племен.
Наприклад, гурони, апачі, а також це
народи Півночі – ескімоси та інуїти.
На слайді ви бачите доволі відомий
вам кадр із фільму «Сутінки»,
де зображено батька головного
героя, Джейкоба.
І також на ще одній картинці
зображено родину інуїтів,
яка зберігає свій традиційний
спосіб життя.
Рухаємося далі.
Також якщо говорити про мовний
склад населення Північної Америки,
то домінуючими мовами є англійська,
французька та іспанська мови.
Зазначу, наприклад, в Канаді
державними є дві мови –
англійська та французька мови.
І зазначу, що в країнах
Північної Америки у зв'язку
з багатоетнічною структурою населення
поширене таке явище,
як мультикультуралізм.
Тут створено умови
для культурного розвитку
всіх національних меншин
і діяльності діаспор.
Продовжимо дізнаватися більше
про населення Північної Америки.
Як ми вже з вами згадували раніше,
90 відсотків населення Північної Америки
є іммігрантами або їх нащадками.
Імміграція до Північної Америки
триває і дотепер.
Переважно це економічна міграція,
адже і Канада, і США –
це країни Великої сімки,
які мають високі стандарти життя.
Два види імміграції характерні
для таких країн, як США та Канада.
Це або імміграція низькокваліфікованої
робочої сили,
або так званий відтік мізків,
коли розвинені країни запрошують
до себе висококваліфікованих
фахівців, зокрема успіх
Силіконової долини багато в чому
належить саме таким іммігрантам.
А ми з вами рухаємося далі
та дізнаємося більше про великі
та надзвичайно цікаві міста
Північної Америки.
Нагадаю, що рівень урбанізації
Північної Америки складає
понад 80 відсотків,
тобто він дуже високий.
Втім, усе ж таки він нижчий, ніж
в Австралії, де він складає 90 відсотків.
Найбільш густонаселеною
країною Північної Америки
є Сполучені Штати Америки.
Найбільшим містом у США, звичайно, є
Нью-Йорк із населенням у 8,5 млн осіб.
Також великим є місто Лос-Анджелес,
або ще його називають Містом Янголів,
із населенням у 4 млн людей.
Можна згадати канадське місто Торонто
з населенням 2,8 млн осіб,
американські міста Чикаго та Х’юстон.
Зокрема, на слайді ви бачите фотографії
з хмарочосами міста Нью-Йорк.
Це – Таймс-сквер.
І ви бачите краєвид на океан,
також із хмарочосами.
Це – місто Лос-Анджелес.
Ми з вами рухаємося далі та поцікавимось,
які мегалополіси є в Північній Америці.
На кордоні США та інших
країн Північної Америки,
таких як Канада на півночі
та Мексика на півдні,
сформувалися великі мегалополіси.
На кордоні між Канадою та США
сформувався Детройт – Віндзор,
він зображений на фото,
це – мегарегіон Великих озер.
А на кордоні між Мексикою та США
сформувався такий мегалополіс,
як Сан-Дієго – Тіхуана.
Що ж, а ми з вами продовжуємо
знайомитися з населенням
Американського континенту
та рухаємось південніше,
до країн Центральної Америки.
Нагадаю, що до країн Центральної Америки
належать такі держави, як Нікарагуа,
Гватемала, Гондурас та інші.
Чисельність населення, яке тут
проживає, складає 173 млн осіб.
І більшість цього населення
проживає в Мексиці,
а саме приблизно 124 млн осіб.
Характерна для населення Центральної
Америки значна частка метисів.
Нагадую, що метиси – це нащадки
білого населення та індіанців.
Найбільша частка метисів у структурі
населення Сальвадору та Гондурасу.
Найбільша частка індіанців характерна
для Гватемали та Сальвадору,
а також еміграція привела сюди
арабів, євреїв та китайців.
Офіційна мова Центральної Америки –
це іспанська.
Нагадаю, що також для країн
Центральної Америки
характерний високий рівень урбанізації,
найвищий рівень урбанізації
мають Мексика та Панама.
Нагадаю, що саме в Мексиці утворилася
найбільша столична агломерація в світі.
Це – місто Мехіко із населенням
понад 27 млн осіб.
І нагадую, що  місто Мехіко є
нащадком столиці царства ацтеків.
Також значне зростання кількості
населення спостерігається
в містах поблизу кордону
між Мексикою та США.
Нагадаю, що мегалополіс
Сан-Дієго – Тіхуана має населення
більше ніж 5 млн осіб і це найбільша
межова агломерація в світі.
На верхньому фото зображений
його урбаністичний пейзаж із хмарочосами.
А на фото, яке розміщено
внизу слайду, ви бачите
разючий контраст між американською
частиною цього міста
та його мексиканською частиною.
А ми з вами дізнаємося про населення
країн Карибського басейну.
Чисельність населення Карибського
басейну не така велика,
як інших регіонів Американського
континенту, і складає 44 млн осіб.
Оскільки Карибський басейн –
це переважно острівні країни,
то більшість острівних країн,
таких як, наприклад, Ямайка,
Куба, мають населення
менше ніж 1 млн осіб.
Населення Карибів – це
багатонаціональна суміш.
Тут є багато представників змішаних рас,
таких як мулати-креоли, які численні
в Домініканській Республіці.
Основними мовами є іспанська,
вона переважає,
англійська є державною мовою на Ямайці,
французька мова є державною в Гаїті,
також спілкуються голландською
та гаїтянською мовами.
І тепер переходимо з вами до вивчення
населення країн Південної Америки,
також надзвичайно різноманітного
в етнічному плані
та надзвичайно багатого
з культурної точки зору.
Чисельність населення Південної
Америки – 420 млн людей,
тобто, за офіційними даними,
це 10 населень нашої України.
Найбільш густонаселеною країною
Південної Америки є Бразилія.
Тут проживає більш ніж половина
населення Південної Америки.
Також найбільш населеними
країнами Південної Америки
є Колумбія, Аргентина, Венесуела та Перу.
Важливо зазначити, що у зв'язку
з нерівномірністю зволоження континенту,
наявністю екваторіальних лісів та пустель,
Південна Америка заселена нерівномірно.
Переважно населення концентрується
уздовж східного та західного
узбережжя материка.
Натомість внутрішні райони
є малонаселені.
Якщо говорити про етнічний склад
Південної Америки,
то він так само строкатий, як і скрізь
на Американському континенті.
Вихідці з Європи є повсюдно, але
переважає їх кількість в Аргентині.
Це 97 відсотків населення,
у Чилі та Уругваї – по 88 відсотків.
У глибинних районах Південної Америки
і нині переважають індіанці,
тобто корінне населення цього континенту.
Також дуже багато білих нащадків
іспанців та португальців,
які народилися вже в Америці,
їх називають креолами.
«Креольськими» країнами є такі
держави Південної Америки,
як Аргентина, Уругвай і Чилі.
Основними мовами континенту є
португальська, якою говорять у Бразилії,
всі інші держави Південної Америки
розмовляють іспанською.
А тепер пропоную здійснити подорож
до міст Південної Америки.
Нагадаю, що країни Південної Америки
мають високий рівень урбанізації,
який складає понад 80 відсотків.
Найбільшими міськими агломераціями
Південної Америки
є місто Сан-Паулу,
де проживає 31 млн осіб,
також це бразильське місто
Ріо-де-Жанейро,
де проживає 13 мільйонів осіб,
і це місто Буенос-Айрес
із населенням 14 млн осіб,
місто розташоване в Аргентині.
Будь ласка, давайте подивимось на слайд.
Як вам відомо, Буенос-Айрес є столицею
танго, саме там народився цей танок.
А місто Ріо-де-Жанейро приваблює
туристів зі всього світу
завдяки карнавалу в Ріо-де-Жанейро
та завдяки статуї Христа-Спасителя,
який простягає свої руки над містом.
Також для Ріо-де-Жанейро характерний
надзвичайний контраст
між найбіднішими районами
міста – фавелами –
та між забезпеченими його районами.
А наш урок про населення Американського
континенту добігає кінця
і пропоную тепер відповісти
на питання для самоперевірки.
Подумали? Молодці. Правильні відповіді
я вам надам на наступному уроці.
Тепер переходимо до домашнього завдання.
Дякую за увагу. До зустрічі!